التعديلات القضائيه وما يحدث في اسرائيل
كان جزءا من سجال بين اداره الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن ورئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو قلت ان
اسرائيل معرضه للانهيار من الداخل ما لم
يحدث تدخل من الرئيس بايدن هي المعطيات
التي
بنيت عليها هذا التقدير ما اقوله من
محاججه هو ان تحالف اليمين المتطرف الذي
اشكله رئيس الوزراء
ابنه نتنياهو له هدفين ومشروعين هدامين
اولهما
اضعاف النظام القضائي الاسرائيلي وقدرته
على مراقبه قرارات الحكومه وثانيهما هو
تفكيك مشروع اوسلو
والتمهيدي لضم اسرائيل المباشر للضفه
الغربيه اي مدى قد تستمع اليه
اجابه حتى الان هم الحكومه الاسرائيليه
تجاهلوه تماما اي رئيس امريكي لا يمكننا
نفعل الا قدرا معينا عندما يتعامل مع وضع
داخلي في اسرائيل ويتعامل مع ذراعي الدوله
عفوا التنفيذي والقضاء والنتنياهو قد
تجاهل الرئيس فيما يتعلق بالجانب
الاستراتيجي الامر قد يختلف في قضايا
القيم المشتركه بعد ان فعل كل ما يستطيع
ما هو السيناريو
المحتمل بالتصرف الامريكي لا اتوقع المزيد
من الخطوات الامريكيه فيما يتعلق
بالتعديلات القضائيه لكن اما فيما يتعلق
باي صفقه استراتيجيه في نطاق النطاق
المصاحف مع السعوديه او مشروع عندما يكون
هناك بلد صغير بهذا الحجم
تنوع الاسلوب الوحيد لحكمه يكون من خلال
ان تعيش وتدع الاخرين يعيشون لا غالب ولا
مغلوب لا منتصر ولا مهزوم لكن حقيقه اننا
نتنياهو قرر ان يحكم ليس على هذا الاساس
ليس على اساس لا غالب ولا مغلوب بل صار في
الاتجاه المختلف هذا ممكن ان يؤدي الى
انهيار اسرائيل كما انهار لبنان عندما
عندما رفضت السلطات الحاكمه او المتنفذه
ان تعيش وفق مبدا التعايش اذا ما اراد بلد
ان ينتحر كما فعل لبنان او كما تريد
اسرائيل الان لا يمكن لاي قوه اجنبيه ان
تفعل المزيد له
هو اكبر الرهينه في الشرق الاوسط وهذه
اكبر حاله خطف
رهينه لكنها من صنع يديه هو
اسست تحالفا من اليهود متطرفين
ومتصهنين من اجل الحصول على السلطه لتفادي
محاكمه تهم بفساد وجهه اليه وقال لهم لا
يهمكم الامر انا اتولى زمام القياده هو لا
يملك زمام القياده هو حتى لم يعد في
المقعد الامامي هو في المقعد الخلفي هذا
ليس اتهاما هذه حقيقه في اللحظه التي
تحالفه يهدده بترك الحكومه واسقاط الحكومه
اذا لم ينصت
فهو مصير حل الدولتين في ظل هذه الاجراءات
المتس
وسياسه قضم الاراضي الفلسطينيه
حلت الدولتين هو في حاله من العنايه
المركزه ويعيش على الانعاش من الناحيه
الطبيه هو الحل الوحيد لكن علينا ان نرى
اذا كانت هذه الحكومه الاسرائيليه ليست
شريكا مناسبا لاي حل دولتين على الوات
المتحده تحاول ان التوصل الى
اتفاقات امنيه مع السعوديه مقابل تطبيعي
علاقات السعوديه مع اسرائيل وتقديم
تنازلات
للفلسطينيين ربما قد نجد انفسنا امام وضع
اخر هذا ربما هو الامل الوحيد الذي يمكن
ادخاله ان نرى تحقيق حل الدولتان الى اي
مدى تؤدي الى انقسام عميق وحقيقي في
المجتمع
الاسرائيلي وهذه الحكومه الجديده
اسست مبادئ جديده في الحوكمه واحدها
ينطبق كما فعل بعض الديكتاتورين في
افريقيا واو القول بانه هذا ليس وقتكم
لمشاركتنا الطعام اذا لا احد سياكل
ابتعدوا عن مفهم عن عن مفهومه عش ودع
الاخرين يعيشون الى هذا المفهوم الجديد